あんやねぇ
ずボランティアでも取り組めで
ふとを不当つなぐ
遺伝を紹介します
まず最初にちょっと皆さんに奥が痛いんですけども今日これまでにサイエンスカフェ
っていう言葉を聞いた事ある方がいらっしゃいましたか
もしいらっしゃる
結構いる
今日は変わった集団生後して行く分かりました普段ですねこういうことを聞くと100
人中の1人も体が分からないということがよくあります
試験官の写真も出ていますが
のは実験するカフェではなくて
カフェでおしゃべりするように
科学をテーマに話をしましょうというイベントです
はヨーロッパで日本で
今では意外かもしれません
僕で約1戦県のサイエンスカフェが開催されています
と私たち3カフェという断罪でやっているのがどういうもの
がをご紹介しましょう
喫茶店を使わせていただいてい
のご厚意で毎回ここを使ってるんですけれども
ルートっ
方がとってしまいそうになりますがまずは場所からしキーを下げようということでやっ
ています
実際の
イベントの様子がこちらです
どうですかねまぁ一場面を聞いて頂けられるんですけど
えあいあいとしていて
powerpoint も使わず
人と参加者が同じ目線で
を話し合えるように意識していますちなみにこのさ
どの形だけ菅かわかりますか
なんか色々久が釣ってますけども
心の中でカレー
てのちょっと考えて
伊丹多くのだが皆が違ったということがきましたが
左奥の男性です
どの方がゲストだかわからない
あの皆さんが同じメス
話したりしてる様子
ちょっと感じられるかなと思います
いうのが私でさ
ヘのファシリテーターの
ています
予算の意見を引き出しつつ
議論を活性化していく役目です
あの雰囲気は良く
でも人によっては専門用語を連発してしまうことってよくありますよねそういうところ
ではわかりにくい専門用語をわかり
いうことは兵の言葉
方に意見を言ったりツッコミを入れたりしやすいよう
をしています
そうで的に難しいことなんですよね
あの打ち解けられるような風
が欲しい点なです
ご自身の考えを深めていくようなそういう
チェーンをしています
50回以上サイエンスカフェを開催しているのでその一部のポスターを持ってきました
開催していますが
形で
比はほぼ半々
だり上の女性カフェというのは生物高の
カフェ
インターネットの宿3
大谷超新星カフェというが宇宙物理学のカフェ
テーマです
のが吹く
以外の方々の本
研究者の方と開催したキャンプ
ここ今一部見ていただけれだけでも
楽屋 ds といっても
いうのがあるんだなあということ
を実感します
機械工学カフェと銘打ってしまうともともとエンジニアリングがお好きな方しか
いらっしゃらないだろうなぁと思って
b カフェの近くのスタッフ
なで1時間以上かかる
イベント名とキャッチコピーを考えに考えてこのネジカフェっていう直球が謎の台頭に
なってしまったんですけれども
キャッチコピー頃になりますか
虹のお茶会回目子です
こんなキャッチコピーで誰が来るんだろうと思われる方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
が
映像が始まっています
どう私自身あの科学の難しい話はちょっと経営しちゃうんですけれども
てみたいそういう気持ちは
マイタイこんな風に化学が苦手な方でも楽しく参加できれずにはどうしたらいいかを
考えています
こうした活動じゃ何のためにやってるのっていうと私たちがこの活動を通じて目指して
いるのは科学と社会のよりよい関係作りをお手伝いしたいということです
20の中で科学をテーマに対話の場を設けることで最終的には化学が苦手でも構わない
んだけども中もしってところからは一歩踏み出してほしいというそういう思いがあり
ます
未来を感じさせる楽しい科学もありますし自分自身の生き方を見直す科学もあります
そしてもちろんリスクをどう選ぶかという価格もあります
そういうような科学お膝を突き合わせて考えられる土壌を作りたいなと思っています
深瀬ウィーカフェで大切にしていることが3つあります
違う3参加で
生きてフラットな場で専門家とを私たち市民が話し合えることを
2つ目はお互いにズバズバと突っ込みを入れたり相手をかわせるような
一方高ではなく双方向のコミュニケーションであること
知識よりも
やり方を身に付けたいということです
教員話きいた知識を聞いてもですね
忘れてますからあの世場所にを忘れていますだから知識を吸収するというよりは科学者
の方が追求する科学らしさとか論理的な考え方って何なんだろう
それをみんなで一緒に体感したいなと思っています
日カフェの場合は私と同年代のメンバーで比較上をしています
メンバーがサイエンスカフェをあの活動に変わっている
モチベーションを割りと様々でして楽しいカー子を伝えたいという方もいれば
例えば環境問題を解決したいとか若手社会人の交流の場を作りたいとかいろんな
モチベーションの方
あります
じゃあ私の場合は何かというと私の問題意識
モチベーションは衣料や生活習慣の選び方です
一見普通の市民は科学技術と関わらなくても生きていけるじゃうような気がしてしまい
ますが
ひとたびじゃあ感染症を予防するためには口を打つかどうか
自分ががんになったという時にどういう治療方法や薬か
そもそもじゃあ生活習慣は何を選ぶか痩せたいって思った時にダイエット方法はどれを
選ぶか
これだけ情報が増えるなかで自分自身の判断を迫られるという場面は意識してないだけ
に意外とか
化学が苦手でも構わないけれども無関心や根拠のない情報にただ流されるだけでは
もったいない
そういう気持ちがさ s cafe を開催するモチベーションです
サイエンスカフェで対話を引き出し私たち市民自身で知的ツッコミと付帯的に考える力
を伸ばしていきたいなと思っています
ここでまた知的ずコミっていう初めて聴かれる単語かと思うんですけれども
知的突っ込みているのは情報を鵜呑みにせず自分自身でツッコミを入れて見ていくこと
です
先ほどの対応と方の話でいうとたとえば特定の食べ物しか食べない極端なダイエットが
流行ったとして
ちょっと待って
ツッコミを入れられるかどうか
あの友達やあのメディアが言ってるからと言って
城北信じるかどうか
菊間結構勇気がいることですよねその勇気が大事
その次にじゃあ自分ではどうするかそれを主体的に考える力を養いたいなと思ってい
ます
号令でいうとたとえば段になったっていうときにどの治療法を選ぶか
宮メディアがこう言ってるからこうじゃなくって
転居のある情報なのかどういう考え方でそう言われているのか
それを
うん自身のレベルでまず考えてみるそういうふうに
てるから自分で考えて選択できるようになりたいなというのが私の想い
こんなことだというかそう対話はそもそも伝わらないっていうところから始まります
私自身は伝わらないきっかけこのアルバイト先でした
これどこだかわかりますか
これはねあの上野動物園の売店なんです
私自身大学の農学部に通っていたハタチの頃上野動物園のお土産屋さんでアルバイトし
ていました
行かれた事ある方はご存知かもしれませんがこの
に検出大学があるのでアルバイト先の同僚には芸大生が多くてます
方から数と理系の学生は珍しいからかよく聞かれたことがいました
に勉強してるの
口を勉強していますよとまあ
よろしいねー
その後はちょっとおかしいですよね
伊藤的なパフォーマンスだから奥深いよねって言われることが多くて
アングラマネーや能や狂言のことと勘違いされていることが多くてですね
私最初それ本当にあの呪文がおり言ってると思うんですよねこれはせてくれてんのか
なーと思ったんですけどもどうやら違うと私も行っている能楽は農業の学問なんですが
うん誘致やの方には学部メイスがつながらない
世界やまあ考えた
相手が違えばいい
使っていることはもう鼻から伝わらないんですよね
たのがこの上野動物
アルバイトでした
阿蘇稼働します
伝わらないそう
伝わらなくてまず当たり前っていうところにスタートラインがあるんです
異なる部分から新しいことを学んだりー
レバー
仲良く会話さ
家の協調や同町の
すぐた中間
意見が食い違うところから始める
そこで対応してお互いの考えを派
考えも不可
赤技術に限ったことではありません
ハープを学んできた
こういう対話の場をつくってい
の同期ではい
カフェを運営している私たちにとって
いるだろうそう
考えて実施
たのが
された方々からは
リスクを考えるための丘江戸ラインになったとか
行動の
ヒントが得られたと言う
なぜわざわざ faith フェイスで対話をするか
須藤に教
思った方
場を設けることについて教
誰もいらっしゃるかも
いうことをお伝え
今日から実践してみてください
愛するとまではいかなくても
一つなん
覚えて人がすごいる場を作りましょう
人ってへ
多彩な価値観が集まります
鎌をつくって
多様な情報や意見があなたのところに集まってきます
味方自分のほうだって思ったけれどもまぁたん
を見ているのか
多様な見方が
には自分
たのか
の人とコミュニケーションする
力になっていく
頭は今日
おっ的呼ミュート頃から
ください
その場を作りましょう
ネスカフェというものをご紹介しました
伝わらない
分かり合えないというところから始まります
主体的に考える力を自分自身を伸ばしていきましょう
えっそうなもうとツッコミを入れるところからです
してい
誰も社会に何か働きかけている
変化
10回を超えた今でも
携帯テーマだとかさー
方々への興味を本当に尽きることがありません
いることはまあ
ことですっ
あなたもこのアイディアに行く
どうもありがとうございました